ted cruz indiana here's what happened  Kasich agrees to avoid the state crews  blaze it up it is big news is it plays  it cool what's the big deal Cruz mrs.  Zelaya that basketball ring and goes for  a rebound Carly Fiorina who falls off  the stage bad metaphor worst metaphor  Governor Mike Pence says he'll vote for  Cruz but likes the other guy too I  particularly want to commend Donald  Trump then clarify this for I am  supporting senator Ted Cruz's dad goes  further me off track could be the  destruction of America Trump responds  with one conspiracy what are you doing  with Lee Harvey out of the world Oh  Cruz's wife debunks another I am pretty  well you again Cruz gets heckled by  adults farm Ted Cruz gets heckled by  children who suggest the punishment when  a child behaved that way they get a  spank Colbert suggested slogan Ted Cruz  16 he hits kids